I think so yeah I had a weird childhood
how so well let's see my dad got a wild
hair up his ass and bought a mansion
dilapidated mansion a poor black
neighborhood so first of all the house
was [ __ ] we barely had running water
it was you know we'd have family
meetings all right go [ __ ] at school
don't [ __ ] here we need the water and
then my dad started running out of money
so he made the back half of bed and
breakfast like old style but so my mom's
whipping up pancakes at 8:00 a.m. and
I'm like can I get one she's like blow
big dick he's a bullet Cheerios you [ __ ]
and so I was like all right sorry Jesus
and so you in you know there's soap my
peers we're workaholics they're checked
out you know there were nice people but
they're just like hey we gave birth to
you you figured yeah go wide ope there's
no attention yes dr. drew I just happen
it's a [ __ ] common Av but boy so
would dr. drew say so he said your cuz I
was like my mom didn't react like I have
girlfriends I'll introduce her my mom
they're like whoa that was tough feel
like I was bombing in there I'm like
look in my life
you [ __ ] [ __ ] Jesus Christ 20 years
of that [ __ ] growing up and [ __ ]
straight like ask me a question it has
to be a random question my mom um random
question where are you from what time is
it it's just like oh [ __ ] sorry I'm
engaged yeah and it's just not mean
she's just like she's just got her
checked out yeah she's just like
thinking about it alright I gotta pay
the bill I got a lot of the plants you
know and you're like you have brothers
and sisters older brother and he's a
genius he's like this you know math
computer wizard and our neighborhood was
so dangerous that he just head into a
computer like as a kid and he just
became like Das and she made friends in
the neighborhood with the black yeah
yeah but then you got into fights and
there was a lot of racial tension it was
the 90s and bikes were stolen and we got
robbed all the time we had this crazy
alarm going off cuz our house was so big
you would just I'd be like an
eight-year-old kid you just hear like
glass breaking and then I'm just like oh
I'm in my room like hugging up teddy
you know hoping I don't get raped by
[ __ ] Leroy and you know you go
downstairs and hey the TV's gone today
you know and that was that was a Tuesday
yeah we got robbed all the time my dad
he's got like he's like n-word rich you
know where he's like I were gonna buy a
shitty Lexus but it's Alexis you know so
the Lexus would get stolen he's like all
right he'll you give me like cab money
to go to school and [ __ ] and and that
was just how it was I remember I told
the story on Rogan but I got my bike
stolen just just street tuff's you know
they would rub their front tyre on your
back tire and that meant like your [ __ ]
and they would just take your bike and
you know you could try to fight him but
there was like three seventeen year old
kids without dads you know no you're
gonna give him your bike yeah and say
you you you get comedy early you know
yeah and he try to be funny and I'm you
know public school and all that but I
went to an all-black public school it
was pretty mixed but it was it was a New
Orleans does have a lot of racial
tension oh yeah oh yeah what's the South
you know and there's so much poverty
there is it's like tourism tourism
tourism and then the rest of the cities
kind of neglect my Amex like that it's
so poor yeah a black neighborhoods it's
just so [ __ ] it's crazy
how'd you out what your relationship
with your dad and mom now well we're
cool but it's almost co-worker like are
they still in New Orleans yeah yeah yeah
they're in that Antron no they're two
two guys broke in with guns and tied
them up and like took all the jewelry
and the credit cards and the car keys
and so they really know that's about it
what's that they let him go they let him
go but you know it might untie
themselves twenty minutes after they
left and they like you know these my
dad's like chew and the [ __ ] ropes
that's that's yeah that's what did it so
they were like yeah we should move we
got robbed a zillion times but I walked
in on a few robberies yeah cuz you know
I see you're so young and a juvenile you
don't know what's happening so they'd be
like a big guy with a like a TV under
his arm and he's like oh we're your
parents I'm like oh let me go get my dad
and the house was so big I would run to
the other side of the house and I
remember looking out of the window and I
saw him running through the backyard
with the TV and I was like oh it's weird
the house was huge huge house like we
had a wing we had wings
wow yeah yeah not a great podcast say
hey you know bad move to be the first
one that James McDuck of the hood yeah
and so everybody thought we were loaded
because you know we were the white
family in the mansion with the lake what
did they show what did he do to buy that
mansion do they have money
well it was so rundown then I think he's
like I got a [ __ ] steal on this was
like a foreclosure maybe yeah well I
think and the neighborhood was so shitty
and it was such a shitty build that he
was like I think he got it for dirt
cheap I remember one time we called the
cops so much they knew us they're like
other Norman's and so eventually they're
like you know what let's go sleep or
stakeout in the kitchen and we'll
actually be there if a guy comes and
catch him that's how frequently we were
hitting Rob they're like let's stakeout
in the kitchen so I was like this is so
exciting I'm ten years old there's two
[ __ ] grizzled cops in my kitchen and
I'm like this excited I hope they bust
the guy and I went downstairs like 7:00
in the morning I ran down expecting to
see some guy in cuffs and the cops had
ransacked the whole pantry eating
everything out of the fridge we got
robbed again
the cops took all the pancakes the
pop-tart cinnamon toast crunch those
[ __ ] pigs
they hightailed out of there at 6:00
a.m.
goddamn yeah and what age did you leave
New Orleans I got I did University of
New Orleans but I was such a drunk piece
of [ __ ] that I just I got like straight
F's and my parents like you got a figure
something out so I went to Community
College Baton Rouge I would have gotten
I would have gotten three police dogs
three German Shepherds it'd be nice we
attack yeah I would be I'd have [ __ ]
though if you don't buy that mansion and
think like that yeah exactly and there
were those know most look like I get my
bike stole and they're like what
happened I'm like God these two kids you
know they were like poor kids and they
were like yeah they need it they need it
more than us and like I all right yeah
well whose side you taking here mom yeah
you know and that's why you grow up with
low self-esteem yeah like a low
self-worth like that's why people go mad
you have so many jokes in your act I'm
like yeah yeah and these people came out
and are paying money I can't let them
down I gotta [ __ ] bring it yeah you
know I see a lot of comic oh that what
else is gone
am i doing here like what are you crazy
this cut got a babysitter bring the heat
you cum-stained let's go free I [ __ ]
agree with that it's cause your audience
exactly I I couldn't agree more
they valeted you know like I'm not gonna
not every [ __ ] time you got people
ever paid there it's costing them $100
for that night better back
no you won't cave you let them down they
have real night comes back give my fine
show who do you think you are who do you
think dance mom ideally sit on the store
like I yeah what I figure it out it was
like can you move up this all day yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]